- Happy New Year!
- Look at you.
- You look so cute.
- What's our new tagline? New me in 23?
- New me in 23 for as
long as it lasts, maybe.
- Hey. Till next week.
- Yeah exactly. (laughing)
This is so '90s,
I'm very into this, yes.
- What do you think?
- I think I could do a little retro.
- I love the 90s. I just
love this whole vibe.
But, so wait what did
you do over the holidays?
Was it fun?
You go anywhere?
- So great.
I can't wait to hear about yours.
My daughters came back from college.
Anybody have college age kids here?
- Not yet, not yet.
- So, you know,
it's a blessing and a curse,
'cause they're used to being in college
where they go out very late
and then they come home,
and then I can't go to bed
till all the chickens are into roost.
So it's late nights, a lively household.
- Oh no.
- So much fun.
- That doesn't sound like vacation, Kit.
- No it's not.
Well and we didn't go on vacation
because with two in college
and one in high school,
our vacation is called tuition.
(both laughs)
- That's where all the money funnels.
- We stay right put. Yeah.
- That's kind of nice though
'cause you've all been,
you know, kind of separated for a bit.
So it's kind of nice.
- I gotta tell you, I'm
happiest when everybody's home,
when the five of us are all together.
It's just my favorite.
It really is.
- The happier moment
Probably before like 2:00.
- Yeah, before 2:00 a.m.
when I'm like, "And where are you now?"
How was yours?
How was the holidays with little bitties
because you gotta do the whole, you know,
Santa comes, Elf on the Shelf.
- We do the whole thing. Yes.
- The whole thing.
- Yes. It's all exciting.
And we actually split this year.
We did...
We were at my ranch for a bit.
It looks like Narnia.
It snows like so hardcore there
and it's beautiful.
And then we were in New York actually
so we got to experience New York,
the like back half of the vacation.
- Do the kids love New York?
- Yeah. They love New York.
They love going.
That's actually one of the
reasons why we split it this year
and just didn't do Montana.
- It's so fun.
- Yeah, well it's lit up and
for, I mean, for everyone,
but for kids especially,
there's just like,
everything is like magical looking so.
But do y'all do any
like family traditions?
Like I know your mom,
like I love your mom.
Every time we tell stories.
- Oh my gosh.
- Does she have any fun things?
- So guys, my mom's name is Bug,
and Bug is in love with Kelly.
- I love Bug.
- She told me today,
she said, "Wear a lot
of blush and talk slow."
So Bug, I'm trying my best.
(Kelly laughing)
- Neither one of us talk slow.
- Neither one of us. It's it.
I have all my mom's decorations
when I was a little girl in the 70s.
She like hand painted stuff.
It was really big in the 70s.
- What?
- So I have like Christmas
villages and all her old stuff.
Then my brother and I fight
over and I got everything.
- Yes.
- But,
so I've got all that up.
And then I used to do the Christmas card
or the holiday card,
which I don't do anymore
with pictures of the kids
'cause they're too old.
- We used to do that. Yeah.
- I love a bad card.
I like when you get
a wonky photo.
- Like the fun ones.
- Or my mom's, Bug would look gorgeous.
And then my brother and I
would be like one eye shut
or one time she cut off my brother's head
and put it on a picture
of me in high school
that she thought I looked really pretty.
So my brother's ear, this was the 70s,
there was no computers or anything.
- No Photoshop.
His neck was really pointy and weird
and the ear was off and
my brother was like...
(audience laughing)
- This is not a joke.
- Love, the Hoovers. Yeah.
I've talked about this on the show before.
My mom used to do that, she'd cut us out
and we never went on
vacation 'cause we were poor.
But she'd put us like in
a beautiful destination.
She'd put the pictures if
like wasn't that exciting?
Like yeah.
- Wait. I can beat that.
- Do you remember the mountains?
There was a funeral
home in Atlanta, Georgia
near where I grew up that had beautiful-
- What is the segue here?
- That had beautiful...
Wait, you're gonna get it.
That had beautiful grounds.
Like impeccable grounds.
- Oh.
- We took our Christmas card every year
at the funeral home.
- Stop.
- And Mom acted like, Bug,
like it was our backyard.
And there's my brother and I outside.
I can't remember the name of it.
- You took your Christmas family photo
at a funeral place?
- Year after year, Kelly.
We followed straight the way through
til finally my brother and I-
- I love your family.
- Are like, "Mom, this is weird."
And then we leaned in, "We're
like saddle up the car, kids."
And I took my kids there.
I'm like, "I know where we're going.
Patterson's Funeral Home.
That was the name of it.
- Oh my god.
That's hysterical.
So many family traditions
are being started right now.
- Started right now.
The grounds were stunning.
- Oh, that's kind of cool though.
- It was fun.
- To be buried
in a beautiful place.
- Yes.
- That's nice.
- But truthfully,
I'm so happy, now I'm gonna get emotional,
to have Bug, right?
- Yeah.
- She's 83.
- That's a blessing.
- My dad, Bucky's 88.
And like, I just, I'm in that age group
where my friends are losing their parents
and so I just feel-
- I feel I'm
in that age group.
- I hate it, Kelly.
- Like people are passing away
and it's, yeah, it's so hard.
- I don't like it at all.
- Yeah.
- So the traditions are, I
don't let 'em out of my sight.
I follow them around.
I just love, love it all.
- You stalk them.
- Stalk them.
I stalk them, I'm connected at the hip.
- It's nice though to carry
on those traditions too.
That's really, really cool.
- It really is.
- Yeah.
- I love it.
- Who are some of your favorite
people to see on Access
or like on a red carpet event?
- You're the same as me, right?
We are so lucky to get to meet so many.
- So cool.
- And it's always a pinch me moment.
Like I'm never above that.
- I love that.
- But lately it's the
really normal people,
normal people like ourselves
doing extraordinary things.
I just interviewed this woman-
- Yeah.
- Quadriplegic, lives in a
van she designed herself.
She surfs, she skis, she goes...
She has a special way to move
around to hike up a mountain.
Gorgeous. I'm so in love with this woman.
I'm like now that's the human
spirit, that interests me.
But you wanna talk celebrities?
Who do we wanna talk about?
- No, no, I love that you said that
because it is awesome to do
all the celebrity things too,
even on this show, but it's
cool you meet these people
and I feel like in the news
we see like just so much devastation
which we need to see
'cause we wanna progress,
we wanna change things, we need to see it.
But it's overwhelming.
- Yeah.
- And it's sad.
So it's like nice when
you meet someone like that
and you're like geez, like
you are killing it as a human.
- And she was, there was nothing about her
that was downtrodden or
feeling sorry for herself.
I mean, this woman has it going on.
I wanna say she was 32 years old.
The van was tripped out and fabulous.
- Yeah.
- I mean whitewater rafting,
surfing, skiing.
She has somebody had built her
all these really cool things.
- Gosh, she makes me feel like a loser.
Yeah.
- We can go
on the fast walk with her.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
But I just think of the human spirit
and how tremendous, it was so inspiring.
- That does feel really good.
It is awesome to do this celebrity things,
people like you, you know, love in movies
or music or something.
- I geek out.
- But those moments are
like really special.
That's why I like this show so much.
- On New Year's, do you do resolutions?
Like are you like, okay,
this is what I'm gonna do.
- Here's what I do. I
don't do resolutions.
I do better.
I'm like, what am I gonna be better at?
'Cause I don't know why I do them
'cause I don't do any of them.
Never learned Spanish completely.
I'm like so half.
It's like I'm just this person
that's like I'll accept like almost there.
Like, you know, like it's
like average is fine.
Like I just, I never do it.
Do you do-
- No.
- I just try and do better.
- Better.
- Yeah.
- My latest with better, water's a thing.
I'm gonna try to drink more water.
- You are?
- Where I thought...
Who's with me?
(audience applauding)
Wait, you're like the
healthiest person ever.
- I'm so not.
- And you don't drink,
you're not hydrated?
- No.
I was thinking I love coffee,
which is why I'm always jacked up.
- I love coffee.
- I tried to do the oat milk thing.
I'm back to my Coffee Mate.
- Oh yeah. Try almond milk.
With just a tad bit of honey.
- I did.
- Oh, a little honey. Okay, I'll try it.
- Yeah.
- But I just realized
with work and stuff, I wasn't
drinking as much water.
So that's on my list to do.
- That's a good thing.
- And read more.
- Yeah.
- I'm failing at both,
but I'm starting off strong.
- I love reading. I'm
so glad you said that.
I love reading, but I never
have time anymore.
- Never.
This is me, I open the book
and I was like, "I'm just gonna
read for a little bit.
- And then you're asleep.
I know, I know.
- I'm out in like two seconds.
- I get in bed and I'm just like,
and I'm always watching things too
because we're interviewing people.
- Yes.
- So you're always like
watching things to, you know,
you wanna obviously be informed
about what you're interviewing them about.
And like by the time I get to like a book
I've been dying to finish,
I literally fall asleep
after the second page.
- There's something about a book
and I'm not even a Kindle girl.
I like to open a book.
- Oh no.
It has to be tangible.
- I like how it smells.
- Yeah.
- I like the book thing.
All right, we'll get
in a book club of two.
- Okay.
- And we'll keep
each other accountable.
- And we'll read
one book a year.
- One page a day.
- We'll get through one book.
- One a year.
One a year, guys.
Hold us accountable, man.
- I used to read so much.
- Me too.
- But there's just no time.
I know it was a sad clap.
Yeah, sorry.
- Those two said, "Get your
water and book, ladies."
- I'm gonna give you an average clap
because that's not really great, ladies.
Okay, so wait, we touched
on taking care of ourselves
but I know that you have
a particular message
that you want to talk about, right?
- Yes, Kelly.
I wanna say it was maybe
last time I was on,
you and I were talking about this
and I don't know if we have
a picture, control room,
but six of my bridesmaids
that were in my wedding,
all were diagnosed with breast cancer.
Look at this picture.
- I don't know
if it was covered on the
show, but we talked about it
and that is crazy.
- And when you think about that,
and most of them stage one
and they've all beat it.
Oh, look how cute they are.
And then little La La down
there, the one in the bottom,
she's actually pregnant.
Stage two.
And it's one of those things.
And so please everybody get checked.
Also in this picture, my
mother is a survivor, Bug.
My mother-in-law, Mama
Sullivan, a survivor.
But is that a weird,
there was something about
that picture that really hit me.
I was down in Atlanta
with this one on the end,
little Jean Bird on the end.
We were taking care of her
with her drains and everything
and I left to come back to California
and then Lisa on the end texted and said,
"I've got stage two."
I'm like, "No, no, you mean Jean.
We were just there. She's fine."
She's like, "No, me."
So all of my best friends-
- I don't understand this in this picture.
- And we don't live, we all
live across the country.
This isn't like we live in one spot.
- Yeah.
- Insane, Kelly.
- So, and they all get their mammograms
or ultrasounds everything.
- But they're catching it.
- [Kit] But they're catching it early.
But it's really scary.
- Be smart, get checked out.
- So yeah, get checked.
Stay on it.
- Yeah.
- And stay on it, you know,
I don't know if you're
supposed to go younger now
or maybe that's a colonoscopy.
I get confused with these things.
(audience laughing)
Colonoscopy's 40 now.
- I go before I'm even supposed to go
because you should know
your family's history
because I know polyps
can run in our family.
So I had a colonoscopy way
before I was supposed to
'cause I just, if you have the means
and you can get it done, it's like, do it.
It's your life.
- And y'all do it.
You think weird. It's
nothing weird about it.
Get in and make sure on that on.
- I'm gonna be honest with you,
I don't remember it
except for the good drugs.
(all laughing)
I know, I came out very happy.
- I woke up.
- I don't know what happened
in there but-
- I won the best colonoscopy
or the best whatever, the colon award.
- Oh, you had a really...
I had a great one too.
- I had a great one too.
- Yeah.
- And when I went in y'all,
I was lined up.
- Very clean.
- Woo! We won!
- We won.
- We got good looking colons.
- Yeah.
Yeah, isn't that hot?
(all laughing)
- Guys are heating up today.
- My colon is incredible.